Transcriber:
First, a warning.
As far as offensive words go,
you are now entering a hard-hat area.
We're going to be unabashed in this,
I am talking to you
about a very particular word,
a very powerful word,
a very "see you next Tuesday" word.
A word that is still so offensive
that the funders of this event
would only let me talk about it
if we censored it on the slides,
(Laughter)
which rather proves my point,
don't you think?
I love this word.
Oh, my God, I love everything
about this word,
not just what it signifies,
but the actual sound of it,
the fact that the C and the T
just cushion that "nnn" sound
into this monosyllabic
that you can just spit like a bullet
or you can extend it out
and roll it round your mouth,
"cuuunt."
I love its dexterity.
I love the fact that in Scotland
it’s a term of endearment,
but in America
it's horrendously offensive.
I love it means something
different with your friends
than it does if you said it to your boss,
it would probably cost you your job.
I do not recommend it.
I love this word.
(Laughter)
I love the fact
that the first three letters
are still the same chalice shape,
all rolling through the word
until they're stopped in that plosive T
at the end.
I think the thing
that I love most about it
is its status as the nastiest
of all the nasty words.
Although that title
is under some contention now.
There are other obvious
heavyweight contenders
for the most offensive word.
The N-word, for example.
But here's what I would say to you.
I know why that word is offensive.
I can look at the history,
that word enabled the brutalization
and racial genocide
of an entire group of people.
It played its part
in dehumanizing Black people.
What did "cunt" do?
(Laughter)
Does it not strike anyone else as odd
that a word that just means the vulva
could even be regarded
in the same league of offense
as the N-word?
Are we saying that vulvas
are that offensive?
Surely not.
But what I want to talk to you today
about is how did we get here?
Has it always been this offensive
and how did it come to be so?
The answer is no, it was not.
But let's look at the history
of it first of all.
Where in the cunt does "cunt" come from?
(Laughter)
It's one of those words that's so old,
etymologists and linguists,
they lose sight of it eventually.
It's the oldest word for the vulva
that we have in the English language.
It might even be the oldest in the world.
There are some theories.
There are also similar cognitions in
Germanic languages all across Europe.
The Vikings would be talking
about "kuntas,"
the Germans had “kuntō,”
Dutch, “kont,” Germanic “kott,”
and I think at one point we had "kott,"
which I think may be due for a revival.
After that, it gets a bit confusing
as to what this word actually means.
One of the leading theories
is that it shares this root,
this Proto-Indo-European root
with this “gen” sound,
which you also see in "genetics," "gene,"
and that means "to create."
Another theory is that it comes
from this sound, "gune,"
which gives us “woman,” gynecology.
"Create," "woman."
But what really fascinates linguists
is this sound, the “cuu” sound,
because that gave us "cunt"
also it gave us "cunning."
"Cunning" originally didn't mean "sneaky."
It meant you knew something.
Cunning folk, cunning women
were wise women.
And in Scotland still today,
if you can something,
it means you know something.
“I ken this.”
It also gave us "queen" and "cow,"
slightly bizarre, which is slightly
less highbrow, but --
It turns up again in the
Middle Ages in "quaint,"
which means "knowledge"
and also means "cunt."
It has a Latin variation as well,
"cunnis," which also means "cunt,"
which turns up all over the Roman world,
including in graffiti in Pompeii.
Some of my favorite Roman graffiti
from the city of Pompeii
I won't try and do the Latin,
but it's translated to be
"A hairy cunt is better fucked
than a smooth one."
(Laughter)
"It wants cock and holds in steam."
There you go.
However, I put it to you
that the word "cunt,"
as offensive as it may be today,
stems from a root that means
"woman," "knowledge,"
"create," "cow."
Has it always been this offensive?
No.
But we'll talk about this.
So when we talk about these words,
"vulva," "vagina,"
trying to offer more palatable
alternatives to "cunt,"
"vagina," the word turns up
in the 17th century.
It's taken directly from Latin
and it means a scabbard.
It means something that a sword goes into.
"Vulva" doesn't do much better.
That appears in the 14th century,
and it means "womb,"
but some people suggest it comes
from the French and means "wrapper."
Both these words derive
their meaning and their import
from the penis, basically.
That's what a vagina is.
It's something a sword goes into.
I say that these words
aren't as feminist as "cunt,"
which comes from a word that means
"queen," "create," "wisdom," "cow."
But when did it first start
being used in English
as we recognize it today?
Gropecunte Lane, this is the first
recorded incident
in the Oxford English Dictionary,
it turns up in 1230,
a street name in London
called Gropecunte Lane,
which was exactly what it sounds like,
this was in the red-light
district of Southwark,
it was a lane for groping cunts.
And there wasn't just one in London,
there was one in Bristol,
there was one in York.
It appears all over the British Isles.
Here it is, the one in Bristol.
Sorry, Oxford, there it is just in blue.
But whereas Glaswegians might be calling
each other and their friends "cunts,"
it seems that medieval people
were calling their children "cunts"
because it turns up in a number
of names, bizarrely enough.
Godwin Clawecunte is recorded in 1066,
Gunoka Cuntles in 1219,
John Fillecunt in 1246,
Robert Clevecunt, 1302,
and a Miss Bele Wydecunthe
turns up in the Norfolk subsidiary role.
We don't know if these are aliases
or if they're jokes,
but we do have a lot of fun
with medieval names.
In fact, originally the word "fuck"
did not mean what it means today.
It means to strike something to hit,
which gives us the fabulous name
of a dairy farmer in 1290
who’s known as Simon Fuckebotere.
(Laughter)
So was it this offensive
to medieval people?
No, it wasn't.
"Cunts" turn up all over medieval
culture and medieval literature.
And they are certainly not offensive,
it's just a descriptive term.
Here's some examples.
The "Proverbs of Hendyng" from 1325
advises women to "give your cunt cunningly
and make your demands later,"
i.e. get a ring on it first
before you give it up.
There's a Welsh poet called
Gwerful Mechain from the 15th century,
and she advises male poets
to celebrate the fine bright curtain
of a cunt that flaps in place of greeting.
It might surprise us that medieval culture
was this open about cunts,
but the truth was, they were more
sexually liberated
than we actually give them credit for.
This idea of them being
in a tower with a chastity belt on
is largely a hatchet job
on their reputation
done by the Victorians.
Now, it wasn't a sexually
liberated utopia.
They had their own hang-ups,
but they weren't that offended by sex.
What will get you in trouble,
swearwords in the Middle Ages,
was religious ones, blasphemous ones.
If you said something like,
"God's wounds" or "God's teeth,"
that’s what you’d say if you caught
your soft and danglies in your fly.
One medieval poet who dropped the C-bomb
with the precision of a military drone
is this chap, Geoffrey Chaucer,
who turns up in GCSEs
and A-levels syllabuses,
although his cunt jokes
are generally not dwelled upon.
He doesn't use the word "cunt,"
he uses the word "queynte" here,
which again means "knowledge"
and it means "cunt."
So this is his joke,
“As the clerkes ben ful
subtile and ful queynte,
And prively he caughte
hire by the queynte.”
A rough translation means
"the clerk was really cunning
and he caught her by the cunt."
Shakespeare.
It's been suggestion
that he uses that play,
a quaint - queynte - cunt,
in his Sonnet number 20.
Here he is.
It certainly turns up
in a lot of his work.
It's a lot ruder than we often
give him credit for.
In Hamlet,
act three, scene two,
Hamlet says to Ophelia, he says,
"Shall I lie in your lap?"
And she says, "Oh, no, my Lord."
And then he says, "Do you think
I meant country matters?"
When David Tennant
played that part, he paused
"Do you think I meant
count-ry matters?"
to try and really drive it home.
Another one, "Twelfth Night,"
Malvolio says of his
mistress's handwriting,
“There be her Cs, her Us, her Ts
and thus she makes the very great Ps,”
punning on "cunt"
and "piss" simultaneously.
The immortal Bard's status
as a smut peddler
is often swept under the cultural rug.
In 1807, Thomas Bowdler published
"The Family Shakespeare,"
where he edited out all of these jokes,
all of the rude bits,
and made it a completely cunt-free affair.
It's no surprise that about this time
we start to get the first
libel laws in Britain,
the first banning of seditious
and offensive pamphlets
with the rise of Puritanism.
For Shakespeare to be veiling
his cunt jokes
in kind of cheeky double entendres
suggests that it's not quite
as free and open
as Gunoka Cuntles and Gropecunte Lane
would once have had.
The Puritans repressed
sexuality, we know this,
and language is extremely important
battleground for sexual liberation.
How do you talk about your bodies
if the very words you're trying to use
are considered to be offensive?
How do you do that?
And by the time we get
to the Restoration period,
the early modern period,
"cunt" is most certainly offensive.
And this chap here, John Wilmot
Earl of Rochester,
is the absolute poster boy of "fuck you."
If the Puritans tried to dam up sexuality,
this guy surfed to notoriety
on a wave of sexual repression
that was unleashed when the plug
was pulled on the Puritan rule.
He uses "cunt" a lot
and he's very naughty about it.
He wrote this poem about his mistress
and how jealous he was
of her other lovers.
"When your lewd cunt came spewing home
Drenched with the seed of half the town,
My dram of sperm was supped up after For
the digestive surfeit water.
Full gorged at another time
With a vast meal of slime
Which your devouring cunt had drawn
From porters’ backs and footmen’s brawn.”
Sorry, everyone.
He uses that word to shock,
and it's easy to look at his work
and think that he's sexually liberated,
but he's actually quite angry
at cunts and their owners
and that goes all the way through it.
From here on out,
cunt is an offensive, naughty word.
Georgian cunts, here we go.
(Laughter)
I'll just let that settle.
So what happens about the 18th century
is the print industry really explodes.
And of course, we being humans,
we didn't just want to publish nice books.
We published porn, yay.
There's a huge proliferation of porn
that comes out of the 18th century.
But oddly enough,
most of it shies away
from using that word "cunt."
In 1785, Francis Grose published his book,
"A Dictionary of the Vulgar Tongue,"
which is basically a dictionary of slang.
And he defined "cunt"
as a "nasty name for a nasty thing."
Such modesty from someone
who also uses the word "buccaneer's boot,"
“lobster pot,” “skut”
and “Mrs. Frub’s parlor”
for the vulva.
This book here,
"Harris's List," this is an almanac,
it's a directory of sex workers in London
at the time, who were selling sex.
And it lists not only
their address and their prices,
but very, very intimate descriptions
of what they do and their vulvas.
But it doesn't use "cunt" very much.
This one here, this is an illustration,
fabulous illustration from "Fanny Hill,"
what's often called
the first pornographic novel,
which was published in 1748
by John Cleland,
who famously boasted that he did it
without writing any rude words at all.
These texts tend to use
expressions like "mossy grot,"
"cupid's coal hole,"
“Venus’s mound,”
but we shy away from "cunt."
Victorians; so despite their reputation
for being sexually prudish,
pornography flowed underneath
Victoria upper-crust society
like a river of slime
in "Ghostbusters II."
They had pornography all over the place,
visual and literary,
and they had a lot of fun with "cunt."
One of their pornographic magazines
"The Pearl" was published
from 1879 to 1880.
and it published in it
"nursery rhymes" every month.
I've got some here for you
to have a look at.
"There was a young lady of Hitchin,
Who was scrotching her cunt
in the kitchen;
Her father said, ‘Rose,
It’s the crabs, I suppose.’
‘You’re right, pa,
the buggers are itching.’”
“There was a young man of Bombay
Who fashioned a cunt out of clay;
But the heat of his prick
Turned it into a brick,
And (it) chafed all his foreskin away.”
(Laughter)
Yeah, well done, Victorians, well done.
Interestingly, it's also
in the 19th century
that we get the first recorded use
of "cunt" being used as an insult.
As an actual, "You are a cunt."
That's the first time
that it's used in the 19th century.
In the 17th century,
it started being used as a kind of
a derogatory collective noun for women.
Samuel Pepys writes about this aphrodisiac
that's going to make
all the "cunts" chase after him.
Charming.
That's when they weren't
stabbing him with pins
for being too sexually aggressive.
Anyway, the Victorians liked
a well-placed "cunt."
One of the most important
"cunt" moments in history is this.
Is the publication
and the subsequent obscenity trial
of “Lady Chatterley’s Lover.”
This book contained 14 "cunts"
and 40 "fucks,"
and it was banned and it had to go
on trial in order to be published.
And it was shocking, not just
because of the graphic scenes of sex
and the language used,
but because it smashes down
class boundaries.
If you're not familiar with this,
it's about Lady Constance Chatterley,
a married woman who embarks
on affair with with Sean Bean here
but with Mellors the gamekeeper.
And the idea is that it doesn't matter
all her heirs and graces and titles,
she’s got a cunt, she’s a sexual
woman and that levels them.
But one of the pivotal scenes
is where Mellors tries to tell her
what "cunt" means.
I won't do the accent.
“Nay nay!
Fuck's only what animals do,
but cunt's a lot more than that.
It's thee, dost see: there's a lot
more beside an animal, aren't ter?
Even ter fuck?
Cunt! Eh, that’s the beauty of thee lass!”
"Cunt. That's the beauty of thee, lass!"
I love that.
Now, despite a jury that agreed
a work stuffed full of cunts
does have artistic merit
and they allowed it to be published,
and you can see the pictures of the people
queuing around the streets
to get their hands
on this book once it was,
"cunt" never really made it back
into the mainstream.
Feminists have maintained
a rather uneasy relationship with "cunt."
This is Judy Chicago.
She led what was called
The Cunt Art Movement of the 1970s.
It first turned up in a film,
a mainstream cinema in 1971
in "Carnal Knowledge" with Jack Nicholson,
who screamed at a woman
that she is a ball-busting
son of a cunt bitch,
or words to that effect.
And in "The Exorcist" as well.
It appears in "The Vagina
Monologues," 1996, I think it was,
with Eve Ensler when she talks
about reclaiming "cunt."
But it's still not off
the linguistic naughty step,
despite all of this work.
Cunts today.
(Laughter)
It was it was finally admitted
to the Oxford English Dictionary,
despite having been around
for thousands of years,
in the '70s.
And then in 2014,
they relented a little bit more
and they added “cunty,” “cuntish,”
“cunted” and “cunting.”
So we all know exactly what that means.
The Ofcom,
the regulator for UK TV censorship
in 2016 released a poll
of what they regarded
to be the most offensive words
and "cunt" was bang up there.
It was on top.
It is still regarded
as a horrendously offensive word.
But here's what I want to leave you with.
What do you call yours?
Because as far as I can see,
words for vulva or cunts
fall into a few categories.
We've got child-like: a tuppence,
a Twinkie, a foof, a minky, a Mary.
Very medical: a vulva, pudendum, vagina.
Slightly detached: down there,
it's down there.
(Laughter)
Bits, special area.
Violent: axe wound, penis flytrap,
gash or a growler.
The taxi driver on my way in told me
that Glaswegian slang for cunnilingus
is "growling at the badger," which --
(Laughter)
I'll leave that with you.
Or they just tend to be unpleasant,
horrible images of fish and meat
and general putrescence,
fish taco, bacon sandwich,
badly stuffed kebab, bearded clam, etc.
Are these better alternatives to "cunt?"
But I think the reason
that we're not prepared
and we can't handle "cunt"
is because we can't handle
cunts generally.
While it's been linguistically sanitized,
culturally, the only cunts
we seem to be OK with
are the ones that have been plucked
and buffed and waxed
and glued and covered in glitter.
So, vajazzled by the way.
The vaginoplasty business is booming.
You can have your labia cut off,
you can have your hymen rebuilt,
you can have your pelvic floor resprung.
Are we this uncomfortable
with the cunt actually as it is?
It's a seat of enormous and awesome power.
It can eat a penis and push out a baby,
it's not a twinkle.
(Laughter)
It is an old word.
It's an offensive word.
But it's an ancient and honest one,
and this is the thing.
This is the original word,
everything else came after.
So welcome to Team Cunt.
(Applause)